citizens of the reject Nation it is John
and it is Tara Erickson and we are back
for some nautical nonsense today as we
dive into DreamWorks animations classic
motion picture Shark Tale starring
William Smith and Martin Scorsese as I
remember from the trailer many many many
many many years ago but hey before we
hop into that Tara how you doing I'm
good I just did a little scuba thing for
you guys in case anyone was like I don't
know what she was doing was she dying I
wasn't this is a it was a scuba thing
doing the scoobs I like it leave a like
for Tara's scuba thing also remember to
subscribe to the channel and when you do
ring that Bell
[Music]
that's right and don't forget to
subscribe to Tara Erickson follow her on
social media follow La eat some drinks
for tips and tricks about how to dine
and wine in Los Angeles and hey before
we hop into this if you want to get the
full experience see everything that
doesn't make these reaction highlights
come on over to patreon.com the real
rejects you can sync up with your own
copy enjoy all of Shark Tale alongside
Tara and I and now without further ad
yeah so let's get nautical are you ready
yeah yeah yeah I'm ready shark it up
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Works logo used to look like oh my God
it is DreamWorks old school I like it
yeah
whoa
oh
at least the worm is tied to the hook
poor little wormy instead of gored
through it
worms are friends not food
oh poor guy
hi I'm Lenny I'm gonna get you out of
here Jiffy you just keep holding your
breath a little wormy
I'm coming Frankie I'll move it come on
Pop's waiting here we go gotcha yay
I was just uh
picking you some flowers hey Mom said
it's not okay to hit okay we're in the
gills
such pretty underwater flowers yeah
Renee Zellweger is in this holy chunk
and Jack Black look at this that was
Jack Black Angelina Jolie is in this
y'all come on now and Marty
so we're about to get some Cinder says
the sharks are gone I repeat the sharks
are gone
damn what is this Brian Square
gup like their cheeky advertisements
Martha sturgeon's flowers okay starfish
tours of course
I've been on a star tour once
[Music]
big fan of seal the actual seal
eels eels eels
prawn shop nice yes
[Music]
it's fake I worked eight years on that
no how'd you produce a fake Pearl
there's so many questions about the
physics here I bet you that Sushi's so
good so fresh hasn't even left the water
yet wait a minute is that a fish serving
sushi
is there no hero Among Us who can stop
this shark Menace hi I'm Oscar you might
think you know but you have no idea whoa
okay CD DVD PlayStation hookup and an
eight-track player for those days when
you're feeling just a little
old school
uh do you have an actual vinyl though
I'm pretty sure
not even a great Penthouse can I be your
financial advisor well that's a good
crazy Joe
's
this is by far my favorite character
oh shouldn't you kids be in school
shouldn't you be at work oh right back
at me huh little smart mouth look I'm on
my way y'all stay out of trouble all
right hey and clean that stuff up yeah
before you caused some foreshadowing
that's pretty good artwork there
God they can graffiti on the whales
that's cool yeah I'd like to see that in
real life as long as it doesn't hurt the
whales I'd be like oh what a pretty
little whale
[Music]
oh my okay going in for a wash
[Applause]
that's great
okay so if you're an eel you have
multiple forms of employment not just
stripping yeah
I'm already punched in
Angie good morning can I help you please
oh may I suggest a barnacle peel removes
lines and salt damage I love him you're
gonna get me fired nah that can't happen
because then I would have absolutely no
reason to come to work you're like my
best friend
oh that's so sweet oh dang
oh no not the Titanic oh no oh God
PTSD yeah
I've lived my life for my sons raising
them and protecting them you're the best
he's the best am I right Am I Wrong am I
right it's all been to prepare oh my God
this guy for the day they run the reef
well today is that day
fix the record
wrong track hey boss what compilation
album is that
yeah that they can move on to the next
track and it's classic all I'm saying is
the kid ain't exactly no killer my Lenny
is a killer look at him
kill him with kindness and charm you are
out what
you're fired
no fire Martin Scorsese there is a lot
of Titanic Easter eggs in this yeah
she's gonna blow
[Music]
grab him
save him from the uvula quadrant
I could look like you
y'all funny well see if you laughing yes
thanks
[Music]
look I've been going over my markers
you're into me for five grand oh I have
to start paying down legal protection so
everything you owe me you owe him the
food chain you see on top there's John
Lena there's me and there's regular fish
oh that's me no you're at the bottom
there's Carl there's
there's whale poo and then there's you
how'd you get separated from the rest of
the fish bring my 5 000 clams to the
racetrack tomorrow or else or else what
the boys will explain
laughs
but Pleasant
5 000 clams and they must be actual
clams right because I'm I'm a little
fish in a big pond a really big pond the
ocean the ocean yeah the biggest pond
I want some of that Mrs Sanchez
all right there you go live your best
life
the top of the reef
where does some bodies live I want to be
here where the somebody's are what's
wrong with down here remember my dad he
worked at the wash his whole life oh
yeah all right he was the number one
tongue scrubber great hair though Dad
yeah dude killing it Earl
dude why are kids so mean your pops had
Pride man nobody loves a nobody that's
not true I want to be a somebody don't
think you're nobody's nothing after all
wait here
if she gives him like her whole savings
I might be a little upset yeah how many
clams you got in storage
what's this
a pink pearl my grandmother gave it to
me
oh from a tiny grain of sand I grew into
something beautiful Dreams Can Begin
small too no uh-uh no I couldn't at all
it'll get you the money you need from Mr
Sykes better not mess this up buddy she
loves you man what's that understand
we've been over this a thousand times I
would love to dine at this restaurant
the vibe here is Tip Top I bet you the
steak is very good Pacific ocean eats
and drinks coming soon
your brother Frankie here he's a killer
throw pop he's beautiful he does what
he's supposed to do wipe your face
you was for both ears I need to know
that you can handle that I need to know
that you're cold-blooded right here in
front of me now eat this
I'm on a diet and I read an article
about these shrimps they're not good for
you I tell you you know how many
calories are in one of those shrimps a
lot no
my sister had a
Pig
oh
no I'm not asking anymore I'm telling
you eat it
the shrimp please
oh god oh no
[Music]
one's looking go get out of here you're
free now everyone's looking good
you're a good person person
huh you're gonna learn how to be a shark
whether you like it or not oh poor Lenny
but he doesn't want to be a shark not
that kind of shark carrying a big old
envelope full of money give it to Mr oh
no oh my god oh Jesus
oh my goodness the race is rigged we
can't loads well what's the horse's name
oh no Lucky Dog you dare gamble it of
course he's gonna gamble it what
Dreams Can Begin small
small just just had to bet it all no
dude how much you got is that is that
only five thousand dollars bet whatever
is extra
5 000 unlucky day to win no oh my
goodness
no
Oscar the millionaire oh this is
terrible
I'm stressed oh my God is that Angelina
Jolie I bet it is oh it must be it has
to be gotta be Jolie it's Gotta Be You
Got a Name Well mine's Lola of course it
is
my name is Oscars
he escort you to my box your box you
can't even afford the gum under the
seats he just laid five grand on lucky
day I think he can afford anything he
wants ugh my five grand no it wasn't
enough give me that sucks take the
ticket get a refund then that's all I'll
be over I'm really super
friend okay wrong you're cute
oh dang Lola she's harsh yeah man she's
laid the subtext out
[Music]
the long shot Lucky Day
the one they bet on
gonna move on it
come on well come on okay catch up catch
up catch up round the curve real fast
maybe maybe it has like Nitro in his
blood yeah hit the knots
yeah he's got that not system let's go
let's go yeah yeah yeah get it get it
get it get it get it
oh
oh no no come on no no no no no come on
buddy ah come on oh my goodness
Something's Gonna go wrong right like
what what is it
um
[Music]
that is painful he punched himself in
the faith was his own tail
this is terrible
all righty Bernie I want you to find the
deepest darkest home
[Music]
oh
sorry kid it's nothing personal it's
just business
trunk shot yep love it this is
referencing all the kids favorite movies
why is it that meloxicam sting out of
people but they have no effect on me or
you hey
good old practical jokes it's the core
of any good friendship you see TV dinner
Eye of the Tiger Frankie I do this what
if I can't do this then don't bother
coming home good point
good point guys guys don't leave me
alone come on there could be sharks out
here I feel like this is gonna be the
start of a beautiful friendship
[Music]
do me a favor don't chew me I don't I'm
not for that
look I'm just pretending so you can get
away and when I turn around you take off
tastes just like chicken nice oh no damn
it dude
that's it I've had it up to here
[Music]
oh snap
oh
no I hate it
stronger so sad can they really bite
through a chain like that I'm so cold
that's just because we're cold-blooded
wow
oh no oh boy is he really dying yeah I
guess so
oh no
ah it's okay jabels
Oscar did you kill that shark
bet your gills I did yeah yeah yeah
exactly exactly how I look that's how it
is
big old shark map 7 500 feet long yeah
right is this like a sing Talk any shock
try to mess around in Oscar town it's
going down bars and you are I'm his
manager uh Sykes with a Y and I'm his
financial advice yes yes
just let him do it he's my favorite yes
he's got puppets I'll watch that whole
movie right there so what exactly are we
talking about here 50 50. you happy no
you happy no deal
[Laughter]
any shark tries to bother this Reef good
luck with that Oscar oh man it's gonna
be open season in a hot second I got the
Titanic life preserver for his memorial
thank you for your kind thoughts
Giuseppe very kind
it's for maturity it might be found safe
and sound too don't worry boys I said
some things to him oh
what's
just what happened how they got some
news about the guy who took out Frankie
to the ground
ah
baby oh my goodness wow
lots of publicity bad publicity I'd be
like um how about we don't tell anyone
so I don't have to fight off sharks
because I haven't fought off any yeah
[Music]
to the penthouse my dude in a penthouse
now
with a like a whole room size lava lamp
nice Angelina Jolie is gonna show up and
there's gonna be drama I feel it well
what does every bachelor pad need a lava
lamp how did you know I love lava lamps
you know what I'm gonna put it right
because she's your best friend Donald oh
no
oh
oh take it back I'm not impressed by the
room size lava lamp anymore just sorry
that it took so long oh that's okay bam
my grandmother's Pearl
oh geez I don't forget anything and I
never forget who my friends are oh hi
I'm not interrupting something
yes you are get out of here Lola
on the edge of the reef that's the great
white time to show your skills which are
lacking
oh where they
oh
that was close super close
Benjamin don't panic
quiet
yo what is with you man huh you could be
anywhere the shark slayer there's no
shark slayer out here
yes there is so they obviously haven't
seen the magazines in shark World
apparently not it's not safe to be out
here at night it is
yeah
sometimes I'll be coughing for nothing
Oscar the shark slayer that's what
people be saying you mean you yeah yeah
when the anchor oh
you're a liar
[Music]
Orca police of course they would be can
you get that shark oh you have no idea
Joe that's great well Gotta Go My show's
on
we're safe for now that's good oh that's
heaven
oh so comfy buggly wobbly
I love you man oh
Bromance in the event that possibly you
know you get hungry don't worry I'm not
gonna eat anyone I'm different from the
other sharks Define different you'll
laugh yeah I'm a vegetarian
oh come on man I'm so tired of keeping
it all a secret and my dad he'll never
accept me for who I am what's wrong with
me oh how does he get his vegetables
that's what I'm wondering yeah if you
want to blame anybody blame me you know
because if I hadn't been out there in
the first place none of this would have
happened yeah
pop knew that he'd ice you for sure
was he The Godfather or something yeah
yeah he is
[Music]
thanks the deal is up the shark I killed
was Don Lino's son I know ain't it great
not if he finds out huh I've got him on
the phone right now that's right Leno I
got the shark slayer right here in front
of me oh boy this is what we call bad
management yeah he's right here shut up
you don't come me shut up I tell you
shut up what hello how you doing let me
have a pie with everything on it yeah
two of these meatballs mushrooms
anchovies get off the line get off the
phone my guys are coming for you shock
Slayer they're gonna tear you Finn from
fin yes I love how the fish are more
advanced and have cell phones and sharks
still have landlines I know come on
maybe I can help oh hey hello hello how
are you doing here you just be popping
up sometimes places ah
oh my God just one thing on top of the
other we actually I was thinking about
retiring you don't want to do that oh my
Lola is intense she has glitter in her
hair is she working yeah what does she
want she's like a double agent
hello Oscar
gee what are you doing here what Oscar
did you forget something your big shark
friend you're a shark
what were you thinking bringing him in
here
ever slayed the shark who am I to tell
him that they're wrong
don't take it personally come on I lied
to everybody
yeah oh geez sharks are coming to get me
and they should
what's the plan all right this is what
we're gonna do Oscar you tell the truth
and you go home
I don't think Oscar can do that we're
gonna paint you up all bloody right and
you gonna swim out and meet the Sharks
before they get here and you will say
stop
that shocks that's crazy man he beat me
senseless he's a stone cold killer man
you need to slay a shark
and I need to disappear
here's what we're gonna do oh now you're
thinking like a family a planning suits
[Applause]
of course you can start a new life now
give me a growl
[Music]
whoa that was pretty good Lenny oh
no it's Pinocchio of course it's me
references
I think I'm gonna puke
Maximus
how we supposed to find the Sharks
player
ouch
[Applause]
just like we practiced flying fish
all right a little help here buddy boy
thank you
wowie it's like Sea World but with fish
and a shark instead of an orca and a
human
all right that's some good acting Lenny
I feel like he did pretty good there
tell Don lame-o that I don't never ever
ever never want to see another shark on
this Reef again boom
I thought they were gonna be like yeah
but there's six of us let's just eat him
yeah oh
[Applause]
hey how's the Reef's most eligible
bachelor been snapped up I'm Katie
Couric here live Oh Katie current Katie
Couric duh
John is just joining the party yes what
did I miss
I saw your big finish on the news nice
smooch lover boy ixnay on the SK man
that's private it's private
whoa somebody's in a bad mood come on
let me see this smile show me the smile
baby off what has gotten into you me bro
how can you not you really have I can't
tell room do you think
do you even be with you
in the Rich and Famous sharks you guys
please at least he treats me like I'm
somebody yeah but would she love you if
you were nobody nobody loved me when I
was nobody
there we have it finally
money and before the
fact you didn't see any of her love
Doodles just go
because I'm tired of hearing how
everything you had in your life wasn't
good enough
including me
let's just realized the irony that Will
Smith is playing a character called
Oscar
s
see you're you made it to the top kid
and you're not happy not right now
there's a lesson to be learned here
Oscar no I don't think so I don't think
so I think he just needs to keep the lie
going you know
hey shark slayer all your friends are
inside not all my friends you mean that
little bottom feeder from the whale Wash
about her forget about it rude she loves
you is that it it's not like you feel
the same way about her
oh Oscar's heart grew three sizes that
time you know what I don't think this is
gonna work out wait good for you Oscar
yeah
oh my God let me explain something to
you whoa birthday
[Laughter]
that's pretty funny sound effects
I gotta find Angie I mean I need to tell
her
uh uh she gonna be gone she's gonna be
gone I just know it very very low
considering all good washes good one
Ernie how many times do I have to tell
you it's gosh you get a whale of a wash
and the price oh my gosh all right
Sykes where's Angie you tell me whale
Wash you get a whale of a washer oh yeah
ah file cabinet top drawer there's a
package get
it
okay be there if you don't want to see
her sleeping with the fishes the dead
ones sure now nod your head if you
understand
let me see you dodge your head like this
now tell me if you nodded your head I
nodded
this is all my fault that's the classic
move I've seen it a thousand times they
take the thing you love how'd you missed
all the Doodles man we gotta save it
whoa whoa whoa look I want to save Angie
too but I can't just Waltz in there and
say hi pop I'm a dolphin Lenny
uh this is a joke right this is a joke
because you know I told Lino
shut up Lino shut up uh tell me that's a
lot of money tell me your real shock
Slayer please I'm sorry Sykes ugh
and my man Sykes has just
begged me not to mortalize all y'all up
in fertilize
and that depends on the individual
behavior of all the individuals in here
individually
I'm not done the boss and if you thought
a guy like me can't get to a guy like
you you're thought wrong
oh good
I barely even know that girl what's your
name Miss
gonna have to tell the truth he's
bluffing knew it
knew it she's a villain there's only one
thing I like better than money
Revenge
your shock sland days are over
[Laughter]
that's what I sound like when I'm having
a mental breakdown yep you you got
nothing Sebastian take her out
dance dancing
oh boy new rules nobody makes a move
without my okay from now on everything
flows through me
and you don't say okay without my okay
okay
oh you just made it back
and take a good look Lino he's gonna
barf her out old school Oscar
[Applause]
are you okay no I am not okay
I couldn't take it Lenny
[Music]
you're alive oh
hey boss it's Lenny he was wearing a
disguise so we wouldn't recognize are
you kidding me are you out of your mind
do you have any idea how this looks this
is
just a bit down I've ever been to it's
not his fault this is between you and me
you took Frankie away then you turned
Lenny into a dolphin
I'm gonna get you oh boy
be alive
he's not the Slayer anymore
look who's stuck in the porthole
[Music]
kids love Scarface
use it use your car wash skills
no no not Ange game's over
oh
uh-oh
no
let's finish the shots land oh we're
about to oh what do you got up your
sleeve nerfan just popped our bubble yet
yeah okay
dude but he's gonna feel so pampered
after this so good nice and shiny
thank you for coming to whale watch man
somebody needs to get me out of the
bubble today
tell the world tell the truth
oh
there we go it was an anchor that killed
Frankie that was true why did you run
away because you always wanted me to be
like Frankie so your son likes kelp
he likes to dress like a dolphin so what
everybody loves him just the way he is
yeah I didn't know what I had
until I lost it get me out of this
so I can hug my kids oh
I love you son no matter what you eat or
how you dress that's so sweet I didn't
need the top of the reef everything I
wanted
right there in front of me well what
about being a somebody I'm nobody
without you no
you know romantic
come here you big dumb dummy head yeah
yeah you're the best henchman a guy ever
had come on Groupon
sorry man sorry come Sykes try again man
don't forget come on don't forget at the
moment
we cool right I mean like the reef is
safe we don't walk the streets you know
yeah open up the city to the Sharks
we're cool oh that's nice Oscar you've
lost everything you've lied so hard to
achieve what's next for you
get my job back Mr manager hey I just
got to put to finish touch on my new
desk
[Music]
and and Oscar's whale Wash is now open
for business
oh they teamed up okay oh I thought it
was gonna be whale and shark wash it
should be it should be right come on now
[Music]
sorry Pop and I are late but we brought
some new customers yay yeah there we go
good did they get free washes then
no no snap it snap it you're not
snapping it I'm snapping it I'm snapping
it's okay a lot of great whites can't do
it yo yo what's up what's up with what
yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
huh Cinema
hell yeah I want some oh hey
oh yeah
it's not a DreamWorks from this era
without a dance number and some hip-hop
references
they know how to cheerlead
hey
not bad
she had a very delicate voice
performance Renee Zellweger
really you thought that I
I well besides Angelina but I was like
oh that's so Renee like with her oh sure
but there's something about just like
the quality of it it was very sort of
like close to the mic
delicate I don't know okay yeah I get
what you mean
okay
oh Sopranos cred in there it was
actually Katie Couric that's fun
inside Christina Aguilera singing it
must be right oh I wonder because I feel
like they did a lot of stuff with like
you know musical guests back then
comes full circle
not bad all right well we did it what'd
you think oh Rob Letterman I think he
directed Goosebumps down the line oh
okay I could be wrong about that what'd
you think Tara I mean I liked it I did
I'm not like oh wow I love this movie
I'm like but yeah I liked it in the end
the end was fun yeah I like the end this
was one of those movies that certainly
when it came out I might have rolled my
eyes because because I don't know like
there is a moment in time and it still
happens now but I feel like it was
especially prevalent where you would
have on the more DreamWorks end of the
spectrum and other Studios but I feel
like they were especially kind of known
for having these animated movies that
would get these like really stacked
voice casts and yeah it would be like
okay we're gonna have like a lot of hip
cool hip-hop references and we're gonna
like do needle drops and we're gonna
reference like movies for adults and
stuff and that can you know like that
can read as kind of corny yeah but yeah
know I mean with the room oh oh oh post
cred Oscar listen baby I know I was a
bad girl you'd have to be crazy not to
take me back did someone say crazy
oh yeah oh okay weird yeah all right all
right
yes that was odd but okay yes yeah
um what were you yeah yeah like this
does come from a period of time where I
feel like you know yeah you have these
more sort of like we're trying to be hip
kind of movies but I mean this was
perfectly sweet and enjoyable and it was
fun and certainly I mean
with the removal of time I'm a little
more open to the idea that like a kid
can easily enjoy this despite the fact
that there are lots of things here that
are that are in their head right yeah
with all the references kids aren't
gonna care about Robert De Niro and
Martin Scorsese and like all of the
random
um you know Mafia movie references that
come with that right uh and the various
you know like there's Jaws over here and
like kids I don't think know who Katie
Couric is right but uh yeah like I
thought that they did a fun job of of
using those things and not like
dominating the whole movie with them see
because I was gonna say they used them
but I was like I don't know that the
story was great enough for me to be like
fully invested and also with those
Easter eggs on top to be like those are
diamonds uh like I I don't know there
was maybe it's just like the I don't
know like the pacing for me maybe it was
just the beginning maybe I'm just tired
you guys I don't know I like the movie
inner child there was yeah yeah I'm not
saying this is like the greatest
animated movie
there was just something about it that I
was like oh why am I not like really
liking this right now even though it
wasn't like bad there were the the
references which I thought were fun but
I don't know why I didn't find it more
fun and I'm assuming because maybe it
wasn't wrapped up in a story that I
really was like invested in and I don't
know I don't know why not yeah I mean
you know as Story Goes it's a pretty
well-worn territory for this kind of
thing it's about appreciating what you
have it's about realizing that you can
you know live your true self and not
have to kowtow to the expectations of
your family or society and yes you
should be honest and you should embrace
the gifts that you do have instead of
selling out to get to the top but that's
all normal tropes right right yeah I
mean it's very well-worn territory for
what kind of movie this is and it
doesn't necessarily trans like the way
it sets itself apart if it sets itself
apart it doesn't like let you it doesn't
like linger to where you think there
might be a bait and switch you kind of
see it coming from the beginning right
yeah yeah certainly maybe that's why
yeah it's definitely like a predictable
movie yeah uh and it's got yeah a lot of
tropes of animation and tropes of movies
that are aimed at kids it's just wrapped
in this package that's trying to be a
little more hip yeah it's trying to be a
little more like Cinema referential
um but for what it was like I had a lot
more I I had a much more enjoyable time
than I expected to when I first saw you
know yeah first learned of this and was
like okay here we go like when he told
me we're watching Shark Tale I was like
what what is what is that what is it
yeah no I mean I remember seeing
trailers uh a bunch growing up and and
yeah it's like it's been there
throughout my life but yeah and two I
mean like it is fun to hear the a voice
cast like this at this moment in time
when so many of these guys were I mean
Jack Black I think is still like at the
Pinnacle right now in terms of like he's
still super popular and recognizable and
successful and a lot of these guys are
too but I feel like yeah like this was
probably at a time where it was like
that was like dang it's insane yeah yeah
and I feel like they let Will Smith just
kind of do his thing and there were some
yeah and like with that there's some
genuine genuinely great times where I
was like laughing out loud which I
thought was very very funny from Will
Smith and then a couple other ones where
I was like that's very funny yeah and
also I miss like Will Smith's delivery
yeah Primo in in some of these like
jokes in his delivery I was like oh he's
so funny well yeah it's like you got
Will Smith doing Will Smith and then you
have Jack Black doing more of a
character and then you have everybody
else kind of doing doing something in
between yeah because certainly De Niro
the whole point was like come in and be
De Niro I'm so fascinated as to how
Martin Score says he wound up being like
a main supporting character in this like
whose idea was that what made him agree
to that what maybe they were just like
you show up for one day and let us use
your voice you read these lines and
you're done I guess maybe like yeah and
it's one of those worlds too where I
don't find the need necessarily to like
poke holes and everything it's one of
those societies where you're like
there's a lot of clever and fun you know
little gags and twists on the fish
version of how Society works and like oh
it's you know Gap instead of our gup
instead of Gap and things like that yeah
you know it's one of those Society uh
fictional societies where I think you
don't you shouldn't think too hard about
it because a lot of the things don't
probably really work if you think much
about them but yeah except like it it
was this was made in 2004 right so that
was one thing I forgot to mention is
that it's it's nice to know there was a
movie out there that existed way before
it's time to show people like it's okay
to be who you are because they're kind
of saying like if you want to cross
dress or maybe be gay or be different I
know
this is me reaching John but I'm like at
the very end of them going like I accept
you for who you are is nice yeah right
for 2004 I think what what that's like a
while ago when it wasn't like a wild
time for everyone to like be who you
want to be yeah when being who you
wanted to be still kind of more just
meant like hey if you have like an odd
uh life path you want to pursue like you
know if do it but keep it like you want
to be an artist or something or you want
to open a hot dog whatever it is you
know like you can do it but but yeah I
feel like there is that beat at the end
where they are like if my son wants the
dresses the dolphin you know like it's
just there and enough that at this
moment in time you are like that's kind
of picked up efficacy with age you know
even though most of the movie is
basically just like I'm timid and I'm
not a carnivore so how do I still be
accepted by my Shark family like that
little beat at the end does make it a
little bit more
Rich of theme even though the movie's
not about that not that at all you know
but at least there's a little touch of
that at the end which I liked yeah yeah
and it's just one of those like Pleasant
flourishes like yeah this this wasn't uh
uh like revelatory necessarily but it
did have like some flourishes where I
was like yeah okay that's pretty fun
that's uh I had a a a a a a a fun time
more than I was sitting here like you
know rolling my eyes or gagging on
things you know and I feel like it would
be easy for a film like this to be more
cringe yeah oh yeah and I wasn't I
didn't feel I was I was having a good
time I think I might also just be very
tired yeah yeah well no I mean I'm not
saying you have to love this movie I'm
just saying you know like this comes
from that time where I feel like
especially the Trope and they make fun
of this nowadays of like why do animated
characters always gotta you know break
dance and they always gotta rap yeah
um but even so like uh in subtle ways I
thought that kind of complemented the
movie because again given who the Will
Smith Oscar is who his dad is you're
like okay this guy's growing up in you
know like a lower class part of town and
is dreaming of moving to the rich part
of town and that's probably a very
common thing people can relate to yeah
and then you know the way in which yeah
you might lose yourself along the way
um but you know like the whole thing
with Lola very predictable yeah and and
yeah like the outcomes like the drama
itself always lets you know it pretty
much exactly what the outcomes are gonna
be oh yeah but yeah I like the
camaraderie between Will Smith and Jack
Black and I liked you know the ultimate
wrap-up made me feel good enough you
know yeah I mean it's like that lesson
of like you can shoot for the stars and
everything but if you're not being
honest with yourself and truthful then
like whatever you gain in that process
or the Journey of getting to the top is
not going to be worth it yeah so we're
like yeah we get that and you can't
really climb to the top without the
gratitude for what you have here yeah
truth but I like some of the settings I
like their uh Titan their their wrecked
Titanic headquarters and things like
that and uh yeah yeah it's pretty fun
overall I I this was what I was hoping
for in the sense that I just want to
have a good time you know get a little
bit of blast from the past yeah and uh
and I mean too for earlier animation
like we've certainly come leaps and
bounds in terms of textures and just you
know yes how great and real and vibrant
everything looks but I still liked a
fair amount of the design choices here I
thought the world again had a nice
little colorful personality and uh and
yeah you know it's a cartoon certainly
but uh it's got its moments yeah it's
not yeah it's not the kind of movie
that's gonna make you cry but I'm like
you know the emotional beats are at
least they're they're on point yeah like
yeah this is something that I I I was
heartened because I was like okay I
could easily see how a kid could enjoy
this whereas when I first you know saw
that trailer I was like who is this for
you know but uh yeah you know not bad I
think kids would like it yeah neat voice
cast some fun takes on different
characters and things like that you know
so uh
yeah Linda and uh one of the or both I
can't remember if it was one or both but
uh one of the jellies was Ziggy Marley
really oh snap yeah okay some fun
additional voices all right Cass I swear
to you guys that was Christina Aguilera
singing at the end it was it was yeah
her and Missy Elliott were on that track
I think according to the uh credits so
uh so good she's so good I mean you can
hear that voice from anywhere oh yeah
it's got the frequency you can hear it
at the bottom of the ocean
um but yeah any any final thoughts
before we hit the road to Tara Erickson
no no except that I'm glad the whale
Wash became a whale and shark walk
absolutely bringing people together and
keeping it clean Under the Sea yeah man
I like that well guys leave us your
thoughts on this classic DreamWorks
animated motion picture and uh we will
catch you on the flippers slipper side
but before we do let's do a patreon
Gabriel listen dude I know you don't
always want the angel comparison however
think of it this way you if you lived
under the sea uh-huh could be Gabriel
the angel fish Wow and think of it you
would have such lovely beautiful flowing
uh things and yeah like beautiful
colorations and stuff like that like if
I could catch you and then bring you
home and and raise you in my own
aquarium so that we could be best buds
and Inseparable forever I think that's
what I would want Gabriel all right he
just wants an angelfish for himself I
thought he was saying like you could be
the angelfish of the entire ocean which
would be like great job everybody knows
you also that you're famous like him but
he's like no I want to keep you all to
myself which is
you know I'm just saying I I think I
think you could get a better deal
Gabriel I'm saying if you were the angel
fish down there I'd say Gabriel away
from me I'd say release them into the
wild let him do his angel stuff for
whoever all right fine you know what
Gabriel just go let's go good
there's plenty of other fish but there's
only one Gabriel and that's fine we had
our time together go Gabriel go he lets
you go out I don't want you anymore
Gabriel I'm throwing uh whatever you get
here's a mollusk shell the whole thing
video like when I leave he's like just
go leave fine I don't love you anyway
him I every time after we film go live
your life yeah but stay pledged that's
the most important you can go wherever
you want as long as you stay pledge so
keep that going and you know keep those
clams rolling in rolling and uh we will
catch you next month love you buddy be
well
foreign